el parqueadero del congreso de guatemala
en llamas cientos de ex militares
guatemaltecos irrumpieron en la parte
trasera del parlamento para exigir una
indemnización económica por sus
servicios durante la guerra civil de
1960 a 1996 ante las agresiones físicas
a nuestros agentes generan el ingreso
hacia las instalaciones del parqueo de
dicho recinto
generando la quema de cinco vehículos
que estaban estacionados en el interior
asimismo la quema de tres motocicletas
y parte de la estructura
física de las instalaciones de dicho
edificio después de tres horas de
enfrentamientos la policía
antidisturbios logró controlar la
situación con la detención de al menos
dos personas dejando también un saldo de
diez uniformados y cuatro periodistas
heridos en coordinación con agentes de
la policía de guatemala se informa que
se ha logrado el resguardo de la
integridad de las personas que
permanecían en el interior del congreso
de la república unos 300 miles
combatientes del conflicto armado
interno llevan más de una semana
protestando y realizando bloqueos por
una dignificación por sus servicios
militares esta fue una de las promesas
de campaña del presidente al alejandro
giammatei para recompensar a los
soldados del conflicto que acabó en 1996
con la firma de los acuerdos de paz
entre el gobierno y la guerrilla
izquierdista
rmc una guerra que dejó más de 250.000
muertos y desaparecidos el 90 por ciento
atribuidos al ejército